hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video beck on a foreigner again today
we're gonna be looking at the new arcade
effect that has just dropped at 4 on our
season 10 I believe it's called the
tessellated aura I don't actually
remember the name but we're gonna be
going through arcades real quick and
getting the type of effects for a JJ
since he's just way easier to blow
through an arcade and then we're gonna
be going through with that and then
showing off the arcade effect at the end
and one really quick tip is that with
season 10 they actually decrease the
recommended gear you need to do the
weekly quest
it used to be gear 144 so legendary but
now it was decreased to 108 which is the
gold gear so if you do have a lower
level character you can actually do this
and perform pretty well without getting
smoked the entire time B as I said we're
gonna be looking at the effect we're
gonna breeze through this with JJ so I
like to be free to enjoy subscribers we
knew a cover the informational side a
phoner that big balance changes here
updates patch notes and links if want to
be kept up today with everything
happening within the world of foreigner
and never miss out on an update that
please they subscribe to the channel my
Twitter in discord will be in the
description down below if you guys want
to join those and with that let's get
started with the video so first up we
have the first match a very simple
one-on-one against the hito kiri
shouldn't be to do bed you know no
modifiers just your standard one-on-one
I will have to get used to this because
I was just I just got off of a five and
a half hour livestream on PC so I got
the timings down a little bit for PC but
Xbox of course a little bit faster so I
think it used to that I'm assuming
throughout this entire thing we're
probably just gonna be fighting a lot of
heat so kiri which I wouldn't be really
mad about to be honest she's a pretty
solid character I played her for a bit
and I'm PC like I told you during the
stream and she got some deadly moves
I've learned a lot through those five
and a half hours so I think I could take
this girl one of the main reasons why
I'm even playing JJ right now is just
for his potential to absolutely smoked
an entire group of people that's a
guaranteed oh it's a oh I forgot
supposed to be a top heavy
interesting yes you can trade a lot I
have to remember that okay
good Perry oh the trade damn okay no
problem
shouldn't be too
all right oh my lord
um I don't know what happened I don't
know if it's just like the bots or the
people that I played against on PC or
something dude but she actually like
[ __ ] me up
I failed like five times doing that
oh that was impressive actually I don't
know what the hell was going on all
right what do we got we have max health
increased for me and a attack damage for
me while no boo she does damage but he
topiary has the increase health
interesting this should be it this would
be a nice fight hopefully I can probably
a cure I should probably take out the
Nobu she first oh we're playing on the
canopy met I was easy all right anyway
well I have a lot of health holy [ __ ]
that's a lot of bars and that's why I
love JJ cuz stupid [ __ ] like this
clearing it in like 30 seconds he is so
good in a gank he's just too good when
he's outnumbered love to see it
that was probably 30 seconds if that
it's too easy I'm telling you
chapter one probably gave me the most
problems I regenerate health the both
Shinobi's have less damage but they
cheat death cannot be all right so I
need to kill heat so kiri first and then
focus on the two Shinobi's or defeat the
two Shinobi's whoever comes at me and
then eventually kill the heat so kiri
but I have to make sure to kill her all
really quickly if she cannot be
unbalanced and she gets her health back
so that's gonna be fun
her name is n MA oh yes she has the new
she has the head she has the headpiece
love to see it
[ __ ] did
all waited she can't be unbalanced
that's stupid to me to do this oh well I
was [ __ ] dumb she just died oh it's
one of these missions okay I didn't know
that that was the case okay I probably
should have read the top left because
also I don't know if you notice on the
top left it says what the objective is
and I have to fight three heat so
carries with low low health but they
gain health by hitting me blocked antwa
max health is in creep of a block
damages increased the tax do more damage
attacks from health and I set to survive
I gain health on kill my health is
higher and my revenge is higher so I'm
actually really in the positives here I
just have to survive for two minutes so
I'm gonna wait it out as much as I can
fight Aki Yoshi here on this track
all right he's dead
let's flutter one-on-one I don't have to
move all right 30 seconds down I got
both guys
Aki Yoshi or Ayakashi she's back no
problem
yeah this is where it's gonna get a
little fishy here also I was hoping that
external attack did the damage it's just
too easy at this point boys it's just
it's really just too easy at this point
it's too easy JJ is one of the best
characters in this game especially for
arcade he just absolutely tears the
floor with this with this thing it's
unbelievable
alright so we got the new effect it is
that's pink plasma shock whoa
okay so I have just discovered that I
did not get the effect ah are you
[ __ ] joking I thought that that was
since that's the new effect that that's
what I should have gotten all right
let's run it back again
what what do you mean
alright so I've read through this about
three to four times and I still haven't
gotten it so I'm just gonna say [ __ ] it
so here's the effect it's the
tessellated aura this is the idol
version kind of cool little pixelated
stuff I kind of [ __ ] with that a little
bit not gonna lie
execution probably not as cool it's
usually not what these are about
I like health oh you know what actually
that's not that bad I like how the
blocks are the cubes bounce and stuff as
for the idol yeah it could be better I
like it I don't mind it it's not garbage
it's cooled up it's definitely not a
thing I'd put on all the time cuz this
matches with literally nothing but it's
cool I don't mind it at all yeah guys
that was gonna be the arcade quest
that's how you beat it basically I
honestly thought I really just playing
as JJ I think the first flight was
probably the hardest other than that it
was a clean sweep Biff you guys like the
arcade effect let me know in the
comments below leave a like on the video
all that stuff let me know how you guys
are enjoying season 10 I'm actually
thoroughly enjoying this season I've
applied a lot of heat so kiri and I
think that she's a really cool character
I don't think that she's gonna be
necessarily top-tier but I think the
heat soak here he's gonna be a pretty
solid pick and four before is just going
off of her feets and just how really
good her abilities are and how they you
know Co the cohesiveness together yeah
like didn't even do Jo guys subscribe if
you're new I cover the informational
site a foreigner that being the balance
changes the hero updates the patch notes
in the leaks if you wanna be kept up
today with everything happening within
the world or honor that we stay
subscribe to the channel my two most
videos are gonna be on screen if you
guys don't want to check that out but
that guys have ever Kris turd I think
for watch the video the Twitter and
discord will be in the description down
below and peace out her yesterday
[Music]
you
[Music]